[Música]
y el número de personas que dejó su
trabajo en diciembre 2021 en eeuu fue de
4.3 millones una cifra menor a la
reportada en noviembre pero que sigue
siendo alta en ese país y es que la
fuerza laboral de la mayor economía del
mundo pasa a uno de sus peores momentos
mes a mes con miles de renuncias un
fenómeno que se agudizó con esta
pandemia y que pone en jaque a las
grandes empresas especialmente a los
sectores como la restauración el
transporte y los servicios sanitarios
que fueron de los primeros en sufrir
estas bajas las causas los empleados que
pasaron mucho tiempo en casa durante los
confinamientos se replantean entonces
ahora sus prioridades y comenzaron a
pensar en el trabajo desde casa como una
verdadera opción es que más allá de un
salario los empleados no vieron otros
factores de su vida como importantes
este fenómeno ha sido tan masivo en eeuu
que ya se reporta en algunos países
europeos y también ha sido llamado la
gran renuncia o la gran dimisión y para
ello entonces ayuda a nuestro primer
invitado del día se llama
alberto bernal es economista y estratega
global de xp desmentí gracias por estar
con nosotros alberto en directo américa
de france 24 y por supuesto en qué
consiste entonces esta gran renuncia o
la gran dimisión y por qué se da este
fenómeno
bueno buenos días muchas gracias por la
invitación esta es una de las cosas que
nos tiene a todos los economistas
pensando como ustedes decían en la
introducción aquí hay cosas que tienen
que ver con la forma de ver la vida de
las personas después de la pandemia
explicamos es algo por falta de otra
palabra decir espiritual o un cambio de
las prioridades de la vida jesús eso es
un evento pero también hay unas
cuestiones muy técnicas que tienen que
ver con con la pandemia todavía no hay
que decir el census bureau en eeuu hace
una encuesta para tratar de entender qué
está pasando y por qué razón hay tanta
gente que ha salido de la fuerza laboral
y por ejemplo es bastante consistente
este número esto es un número mensual
más o menos 3 millones de personas en
eeuu siguen diciendo que siguen que
están extremadamente
extremadamente preocupadas con la
pandemia mejor dicho que prefieren
quedarse en su casa encerrados sin salir
a la calle porque tienen mucho miedo de
que se vayan a contagiar de covite y
este número 23 millones de personas es
una cantidad y en la mayoría de estas
personas estos 3 millones de personas
tendían a trabajar en un hospital en
hospitales digamos en hoteles en
restaurantes etcétera entonces por eso
es que ha habido tan hay tanta
dificultad en este momento para muchos
industriales muchas gentes de negocios
para conseguir a personas que quieran
trabajar pues por un salario específico
y pues la verdad esto es difícil de
contrarrestar porque cuando una persona
sigue muy preocupada por la pandemia
pues sigue muy preocupada por la
pandemia y no hay no hay mucho que se
puede hacer en el corto plazo alberto es
decir que entonces la gente está
prefiriendo su calidad de vida digamos
su vida misma por encima del trabajo y
también le quiero preguntar en otra
pregunta que me encantaría y pues
resolverla aquí con usted es decir estos
problemas que ha tenido la economía de
eeuu la inflación y toda esta cantidad
de problemas que hemos visto también se
puede digamos ver afectados por esta
gran renuncia por esta estas personas
que dejan el ámbito laboral a primeras
sin duda alguna a ver hay un número que
es bastante técnico pero pero tengo que
nombrar lo que es la tasa de
participación laboral entonces en eeuu
más o menos el 62.5 por ciento de las
personas en edad de trabajar estaba
trabajando en el día antes de que se
iniciara la pandemia 62.5 eso se bajó a
60 por ciento de la población y apenas
hemos recuperado alrededor es de 61 por
ciento o sea todavía hay muchísima gente
que sigue totalmente por fuera de la
fuerza laboral otra vez y esas personas
no es que no estén esa persona
simplemente
decidieron cambiar su forma de ver la
vida quizás hay otro otro tema también
muy importante que es también técnico
pero hay que decirlo que es que como en
eeuu hubo tanto trauma por las y por el
cierre de los colegios entonces pues las
familias no sabían si los niños iban a
ir al colegio ni varyná del colegio si
va a estar cerrado si iban a los
profesores iban a dar clases o no
entonces esa imposibilidad de planear de
las familias si los niños tienen colegio
no en muchos casos mantuvo por ejemplo
la mamá
fuera la fuerza laboral durante la
pandemia y muchas personas todavía
siguen muchas más bajas siguen por fuera
la fuerza laboral porque todavía existen
incertidumbres si los políticos van a
cerrar los colegios en eeuu o no puede
en este momento hay como 6000 colegios
cerrados en eeuu por la pandemia
entonces hasta que no se normalice esa
situación de cierre de los colegios
también esas personas que estaban
trabajando antes pues no no van a volver
a eso entonces por eso es que es tan
importante avanzar en esta normalización
de la educación presencial ahora alberto
estamos hablando de eeuu porque por
supuesto pues ahí se originó todo este
término de la gran renuncia no pero
trasladando todo de eso a nuestra región
a nuestra región latinoamericana américa
latina' podríamos ver algo similar
digamos las condiciones de economía y
laboral están en disposición para que la
gente también pueda decir pues yo
renuncio por la pandemia o porque
prefiero mi calidad de vida esa que pasa
con américa latina' y si podíamos y si
podemos ver algo similar
pues es difícil que veamos algo similar
porque pues aquí tenemos que tener en
cuenta también que eeuu un país
desarrollado con una digamos con una
capacidad de darle subsidios específicos
a las personas o de ayudar a las
personas que están por fuera de la
fuerza laboral o que permiten tener
porque eso también ha sucedido también
muchas personas por ejemplo muchos
camioneros personas que manejaban un
camión 10 10 10 horas al día etcétera
etcétera y recogían los containers en
los puertos etcétera esas personas han
replanteado su vida muchas de esas
personas ha replanteado su vida y por lo
tanto por ejemplo hace número o hace
engorde sexuales en otra cosa diferente
que les da menos ingresos es cierto pero
que con el rap plan el replanteamiento
que han hecho en su vida para con por
por el shock de la pandemia pues
prefieren estar en esta situación en
nuestro de nuestra región es menos
probable que suceda eso por qué porque
pues somos una región pobre entonces las
personas tienen que trabajar
y entonces yo no oí de las mismas
historias de falta de oferta laboral en
colombia en méxico en chile en perú
etcétera comparado con lo que oigo en
eeuu y comparado con lo que se oye
también de vez en cuando en europa en
europa es menos menos es menos claro
este fenómeno pero también algo de eso
se está viendo pero en europa quizás sí
ya sea también también muy parecido al
tema de eeuu de que la gente quizás se
replantea su trabajo su vida y dice yo
para que trabajaba 40 horas y el día más
bien trabajo 20 horas y toco guitarra en
el resto del tiempo que lo que más me
gusta hacer y entonces le pregunta
alberto qué va a pasar con estas
vacantes de empleo quién va a ser ese
trabajo que ya nadie quiere hacer
pues mi estimado esto lo que va a
suceder es lo mismo que está pasando en
japón desde hace 20 años que es que cada
vez que uno entra a un mcdonald's oa un
burger king etcétera wen dice en eeuu
cada vez menos personas y cada vez lo
recibe más es uno una pantalla samsung
de 52 pulgadas donde uno presiona para
pedir su cocacola sus papitas y su
sándwich de pollo no o sea cada vez más
automatización de los procesos
porque porque pues entre mayores sean
los salarios para esa escala de la
población mayor el interés del dueño de
la franquicia de un wendy's o de un
mcdonald's para automatizar su
restaurante porque o si no se le pone
muy difícil dar un producto a un precio
adecuado entonces eso lo están
reportando muchos muchos muchos estudios
también eeuu una aceleración en el
proceso de automatización sigue en los
procesos para para poder contrarrestar
esto pues ahí quería llegar también un
tema muy interesante para tratar la
automatización del trabajo y pues estos
trabajos que ya no van a ser
presenciales y luego le van a hacer
máquinas por nosotros es un abrazo con
muchísimo gusto saludos a la audiencia y
gracias por tener el programa